[Music]
in big dick problems news to hear about
you guys submitted by a house always
wins
I do that's right but I still gamble
makes it fun whether they're talking
about property yeah like if you went to
if you like like if you always won
that would be hell if you're a gambler
and you always won that that's not what
you want you want that thrill of that
knowing that you could possibly lose no
then you're not gambling or gambling
there you wanna win you wanna alert kids
that's called having a job yeah you got
gambling [ __ ] you get a paycheck every
week alright a man was cleared of a sex
crime after the court accepts that he
was merely well-endowed
oh why he obliterated guts oh he was
just in public yeah I know what happened
he was on a subway train they're all
holding onto the latch right and then
the girl was like what the [ __ ] someone
is dry-humping the [ __ ] out of me dick
is touching people come on it's so big
it's so big it's probably yeah but you
can turn it you know oh you know what it
is it was the summer tired dick you know
you got summertime in New York really
short shorts dick came out sex offender
if you got big-ass dick he's not
supposed to be wearing short shorts like
you the mob saying it has to be fair to
big ass big people
well they don't forget to wear whatever
you want to wear big TV [ __ ] get to
wear whatever they want away no but it's
a nipple pops if you're wearing like you
can't wear like a string and your nipple
pops on you like it's because of my big
titties no no you're supposed to wear a
proper bra yeah all right so this man's
name is Costa and you guys guessed the
location correctly it was in a subway
where this happens
good job New York oh my god did you read
this no David that support she is baby
you're so smart about big dicks
so this 61 year old man named Costa he
was [ __ ] yeah he was sitting in the
subway and this woman named Alicia she's
32 years old just a cool name yeah she
was recording this man I like she
claimed that he was masturbating I use
adjusting his big she was adjusting his
big ass dick
so she's harassing him yeah yeah why are
you looking at his crotch that's like if
I was a dude and I'm taking a video some
chick who's like you know she's doing
something with her tits or something
like that we'd be the pervert yeah but
chicks can be like oh my god what it's
doing with its dick like this double
standard video I don't have the video
okay okay yeah I think it's pretty big
where is it oh my god well has a burrito
in there but now we're gonna I'm not
gonna be able to eat lunch how is he
jacking up I don't tell you not his
pants yeah so they're saying that in the
video that he was adjusting for like 10
seconds straight so like a little too
long to be adjusting you know that oh
you're gonna give me some an adjustment
timeframe that I could only adjust my
date eight-second literally he went to
court and they're like he goes Your
Honor I have to show you something we go
behind the Pew he looks over whip study
those case closed all right done done
throw it up throw it up you know what's
great about that he on court record he
has a big dick yeah that's where it took
61 years for that to happen but he made
this on the books
yeah that's gotta be his tinder profile
you know me on the books I got a big tip
on the book
lives there all the wheelchairs and they
all have pictures like he's famous 40s
I'll do it you know but people have to
point at his dick that's a red tights
everywhere yeah this whole thing sucks
because he is an Albanian native it was
living in Brooklyn go Albanians like you
keep reppin heart now he remains in
federal immigration custody facing
deportation because of this case was
undocumented I know it's just that they
like if you get out now
they'll kick you other country kick you
out of the country even though they're
like okay you're innocent well that's
the thing now he's waiting he's hoping
that the acquittal will boost his hopes
of stay and I got to stay in America
because I got a big dick yeah yes but
they're saying though that say one thing
so like the defense team was saying that
like no this Lea Alicia she's the creep
yeah creep ranch
well first of all she was recording him
right oh it was just the two of them in
that car like there was she could have
moved if she wasn't really that
uncomfortable but she was the one that
was just sitting directly afraid from
what she needs how much she needs some
dick yeah is she an immigrant as well
they could get deported because I would
love that
mmm her last things Richardson so I'm
doubt it [ __ ]
never mind yeah how old is she 32
tightest [ __ ] how would you want to bet
she's [ __ ] ugly as hell too yes do
you want to bet she is [ __ ] hitting a
picture what somebody is probably an
anti-social too because I would think
that like people handle things in
different ways yeah you don't know what
jacking off looks like you know there's
a there's a kind of way you would just
kind of be like well I mean there's a I
mean now this is this is won't talk
about there's a whole thing now the
court case was thrown out because he
walked him first she came in late she
was really lucky they're like closed no
they didn't hideous and there's a
difference between they making eye
contact with it yeah but he didn't see
her filmy probably just like mine is
he what my name is oh man I just adjust
all my junk without you having a problem
with it no I am NOT a pieces no worried
about what everyone else is doing you
know oh god I can't believe how dare he
yeah so they were saying like part of
the closing argument was the fact that
mr. colossi may have a big penis wait
may have a big penis that this woman was
enamored with from sitting from across
his back we does not make him guilty of
a crime oh wow they said that in court
that she was hypnotized by day I just
really want the lawyer to come in and
just be like your honor
look at this creature over here she is
disgusting all you hear is from the bed
he stay like this is the courtroom table
my balls your honor yeah yeah so she so
the judge who's a woman said that she
didn't vote that he was pleasuring
himself that there was any public
lewdness here but the public lewdness
well they have the video though does not
require exposure of a private part so
like if you really want you know you
could be in a subway there's some bad I
understand yeah cuz if you're recording
a guy like fondling his dick for
snitching she should she could have
fishy she could be claiming that she
felt threatened and and because if he's
touching himself and there's just them
two there she was doing it for her own
protection and defense because right
when he got out of the trench the subway
he she also got out on that same weird
wow that sucks I hope she feels tackle
yeah yeah like why is she trying to ruin
someone's life maybe she's been a victim
of it before and she's like [ __ ] like I
don't want to go through this
let me just protect my good point to let
me clarify something so she did get off
on the same stop she did contact a
police officer but then he they didn't
get him right then and there the way
that they arrested him was because he
was taking down posters with his face on
it from that video oh my god oh she went
out of her way to make posts and she
wasn't even physically affected by it
like she didn't like he didn't try the
light Club he was just like oh well she
what are the facts like what was he on
the plate was he in the video looking at
the camera out was he low like this
taking your camera he sporadically
glances in her direction train with him
yeah she's recording him adjusting his
dick before you do I'm saying I don't
know if what he was doing was
appropriate or not I don't know if she
felt threatened or not whatever it would
happen all I'm saying is should this
have gotten to the level of calling the
police it's my point
yeah what happened to her just being
like one getting up moving or even and
he was being inappropriate saying
something about that I hate because I
don't make the guys you know stop let me
take action yeah they could talk about
it action they absolutely love you
though like you
I found the girl by myself for a tiffith
girl bye don't say anything but
typically say it so you would say
anything right but before you pull out
the phone there steps between that right
like if it was danger would you remove
yourself from it that's all we're saying
stay in danger recording it like that
yeah but if she did feel some sort of
friend which of course now it's been
proven that she's [ __ ] blowing this
out of proportion right but if she's
like damn like if he's willing to do
this because in her mind he was really
going at it
right oh she's make a pizza dough so if
he's crazy enough to do this like what
might be his next step to he might have
victim next time so that's her why I
don't think that I see okay we're trying
to question this person's intentions
because it sounds like to me like the
point of it was
to make a scene that's exactly that
point that was like because like boy
it's one thing to be it's one thing to
be like when we pull this out because I
feel threatened no no to me it's like
you've already had the forethought of oh
I'm a gifted this is perfect and then
she sounds like so somebody that
probably has move which is [ __ ] up
incidents of this because if you have a
phone if you have a fish it across from
a guy you have a phone that means if
you're in a car like if I'm sitting
across from you like this I could get up
and go over there
I could still film and it means you're
not that afraid so I just think it's
that weird thing but again it's like a
weird some perspective that we live in
right now is like what you just said is
I guess a guy perspective I mean it's
like because it is a guy thing I mean if
you're looking across from a guy doing
like that you're like you as a guy
you're just like it's [ __ ] you doing man
if he's no I mean yeah it's just a Matt
it's just a matter of just being like
what the [ __ ] you doing and then or just
be like I'm getting you get up and get
this is no difference between adjustment
and fondling so like most guys are just
because discomfort and the whole reason
is because you don't want your dick
popping out of your pants so you're like
oh [ __ ] and then you recognize that so
you adjust or what I'm here by his
biggest part even if you got a normal
dick you know like it happens because it
pops all those normal big guys cuz it's
you sit wrong or whatever it's popping
out whatever and and you want it you you
don't want people add you don't have a
dick and I don't like how she ended up
having to take that video and like going
at Kinkos and pretty much well you just
you know who knows I mean I wish there
was video of the incident video I'm
talking about I wished it was like a
video scene like in the train scene like
well like what she were doing what she
was happy what was happening because we
don't know we have to take their word
for it you know but I just don't like
this idea that it's like they don't have
video camera inside of a subway they do
that's still a court case yeah
[Music]
[Music]